i was trying to do some research like
the asian paint
like people are getting attacked
black men that have been attacking asian
um
earlier this week investigative
journalist group project
veritas published two other parts of
their undercover operation
in which cnn executive charlie chester
admitted that the outlet
had a predetermined agenda to get donald
trump
out of office and that it had played up
the covet 19 death
toll to secure higher ratings
let's go live now to nick jevis nick is
managing editor of the newsroom
project veritas nick welcome the video
raises some serious questions on how cnn
covers issues crucial to america
do you think what we heard there in
conversation is really company policy
well it's hard to say we can speak to
the fact that this
technical director charlie chester he
was certainly part of the culture
he had cited having overheard jeff
zucker having a special red phone he
called it the bat phone i believe
that he would use to call producers to
say to continue to push the covet
counter the death counter
so even if he was lower on the totem
pole he had access to the culture
he overheard things and he said the
quiet part
out loud and it was damning it's it's
very disturbing what's been said and
words like propaganda manipulation and
now
racial issues being conflated being
you know repressed all these things came
out
he just kept talking and it got worse
and worse and worse and
you could see from the clips you played
just that's just not even the half of it
so i would encourage your viewers to go
to projectveritas.com and watch the full
clips because
they're uh shocking yeah it's certainly
interesting
nick does this reflect across all
mainstream journalism in the us in your
opinion
is this really what we've seen going on
other
networks too
i think like anything you're going to
have some good you're going to have some
bad but
sadly in my personal experience i was a
former journalist i've worked
at different types of outlets yes for
the most part
a lot of american outlets cnn wouldn't
even respond to us
even a couple years ago they'd be at
least confident enough to reply
and and try to defend themselves now
it's a question of we talk to you
or in your friend and we give you
content con you know comments and all
that or we hang up on you
uh james o'keefe our ceo tried to reach
out to oliver darcy to talk about this
to allow the network to explain
what charlie chester was saying to to
defend it to say if he was fired none of
that was even
considered they were hanging up the
phone the minute they heard james's name
so this is a phenomenon that i think is
spreading unfortunately
and that's why we're trying to expose it
at cnn and get other people to come
forward and share their story at other
outlets
are there other more revelations to come
on this
always always we have people everywhere
we're always looking
for newsworthy stories we have insiders
at
all over these networks and and we need
more we need more brave insiders to come
forward
to send us information you can go to
veritastips
protonmail.com you can send information
that way
you can go to the website and as long as
we have brave people coming forward
we will have stories to tell that are
being repressed that are being hidden
in darkness and that's where we get most
of our content but to answer your
question again directly yes
there's always more to come we always
have more to tell the american people
that's being hidden
can you give us an idea of any of that
well i can just say that they're they're
going to continue to be
i believe shocked and i think they're
going to start seeing things from a
different light
it seems that the rules that as a
society that we all thought were in
place are no longer in place
there is no more rule book but i don't
want to go too
into detail on what we have coming up
but i think if if you look at our past
clips
if that's any uh measure of it stay
tuned and buckle up
how did you translate the clip that we
showed there nick about
um the technical director at cnn
essentially saying
we our aim was to help black lives
matter
how deep does that go
from just the clip you know speaking
just to that with in charlie chester's
words
he was speaking as if they were an
advocacy group and this is a network
that uses the
tagline the most trusted name and news
does the most trusted name in news
you know collude directly or indirectly
with black lives matter
that's a question for the american
public to ask we've put that out there
and i think it's up to the people to
step forward and start asking these
questions
we've gotten the ball rolling but it
takes more than just these clips
to make change or to answer that
question in full
so we need more information to find out
after being caught out like this do you
think it will affect their coverage
at first we had thought we could at
least get a statement and then see if
that
you know in turn would affect their
coverage but i think their silence
speaks volumes
in that they have no interest in
engaging with us project veritas
that they have no interest that one of
their employees was out there
admitting that the network is propaganda
that's his words not mine
and all these others are pretty stark
that was a pretty startling sentence
that i mean he's talking about
manipulating people mentally
he talks about that it was the reason he
wanted to get involved with cnn in the
news because they were
pushing trump out and because they were
propaganda this is
you know this is concerning this is
something that the american people
should be looking into
this is something they should be
studying and this is something that they
should know about because
anything this big that i mean people
make
value decisions that affect their lives
every day based on the news
and if you're telling them you're real
and in
you know your off hours you're saying
that you're completely fake your
propaganda
that needs to be investigated that needs
to be looked at further so i encourage
people continue to tweet about this to
put it on your social media platforms
to come forward and to check the network
hold them accountable
they promised you news and they're not
giving you news from what charlie
chester says
in terms of media regulators or
something tackling this
can can you see that happening or has it
gone beyond that
i think in my personal opinion uh it may
have gotten beyond that but i don't know
it's very hard to tell these days what's
going to happen
it's very unpredictable environment that
we're in politically and socially
it's very volatile it changes seemingly
by the day
so it's hard for me to look into the
future on something like that but i will
say that
i wouldn't be surprised if we were past
that let me put it that way
and i don't think that it's going to
change unless
the people come forward it's not a
regulatory body it's not the senate
and in some cases it's not even project
veritas because the content is coming
from
whistleblowers from brave people so as
long as more brave people come forward
we'll get
more answers to these questions that
you're asking but only if people have a
conscience and step up and and we will
hear your story out at project veritas
just finally do you fear a backlash from
mainstream media because of what you've
put on
no no we don't fear any backlash that's
why we're working here we're here
because we're beyond that point
we believe that the american people
deserve to know the truth we're truth
seekers we're not political
we're not looking for gain we don't do
this for money we don't do this for fun
we don't do this for sport
this is for truth so it doesn't matter
the backlash we're going to continue
we're going to keep going until the full
truth is exposed and
and then some it's a never-ending fight
nick thanks for your time and your
thoughts very interesting
develop in the last few days as regards
that and we do hope to see what else
you've on earth
uh soon as well nick gives managing
editor of the newsroom
at project veritas thank you stay tuned
you